ukraine's enemies are heroes here in
russia's towns and villages as the
country's losses grow
yes vina is a tiny place and everyone
knew 21 year old sergey konyakov
we don't know where or how he died but
according to the ukrainians his regiment
the 104th air assault unit of the 76th
division had served in and around
butcher
natalia is the mother of his
does she think there was any
purpose to
to what he was doing
sergey's mother lost her husband to
covid nine months ago and sergey was her
only child
his grandmother is too upset to talk to
us
the tragedy that is ripping through
ukraine's towns and villages is playing
out in russia too of course it's not so
obvious and it's not so large scale
there aren't bodies strewn across these
streets there's not the mangled wreckage
of armor there's just the wind and the
snow and the barking of dogs just as
there would have been in ukraine's
villages a little over a month ago but
the sense of loss
that's here also
and the suspicion those two men are from
the local authority alerted to
foreigners in their midst they ask us to
leave and tail us to make sure that we
do
interfere not far from yes military
cargo planes lumber through the skies
there's a large military airfield close
and they're bringing kits or troops or
bodies back from the front
state tv has fallen on receptive ears in
fear
nobody
do you think that the ukrainians have
time to fake lots of dead bodies on the
street when they're in a big battle with
russians
exterior
and then there's the anti-american
subtext which underlines it all
america
america
military academy is named after the
soviet general georgi zhukov the soviet
defeat of nazi germany elevated almost a
cult status during putin's time in power
now channeled into the messaging around
ukraine as being an anti-nazi mission
there is the job to defend your
motherland this poster says
to fight perhaps to die even if your
motherland isn't under attack
dynamagne sky news tv russia